bonsoir merci de nous rejoindre pour
votre édition du weekend du journal de
la rédacctiontion de TVfil nous sommes
le vendredi 25 mars voici les principaux
titres alors que les élus ne cessent de
dénoncer le désengagement financiers de
l'État sur le plan local ils doivent
plancher sur l'élaboration de leur
budget pour l'année à venir jeudi soir
se tenait le conseil communautaire de
l'agglomération de Saint-Quentin en
Yveline retour sur les premiers
arbitrages organisé chaque année depuis
17 ans par l'association Planète science
î-defrance la rencontre régionale des
trophées de robotique permett à des
jeunes âgés de 7 à 18 ans venant de
divers horizons de travailler en équipe
et de construire eux-mêmes des robots
philo guidés originaux la finale se
déroule ce samedi à Montini nous en
parlerons avec nos invités et comme
chaque vendredi retour tout à l'heure
sur les faits importants de l'actualité
depuis le début de la semaine élection
législative dans la 2uxème
circonscription des yelin premier signe
tangible du rapprochement du département
avec les hautes scènes ou encore Journée
mondiale de la
trisomie nous débutons avec cette
information la condamnation de trois
hommes et une femme ils ont entre 19 et
24 ans et viennent d'être condamnés donc
par le tribunal correctionnel de Paris
pour avoir préparé depuis trapppe leur
départ pour la Syrie au lendemain des
attaques de Charlie hebbdo c'était donc
en janvier de l'année dernière des
peines de 3 à 5 ans de prison ont été
prononcées
la réunion à présent hier soir jeudi des
élus de l'agglomération de Saint-Quentin
en Yveline un conseil communautaire
presque entièrement dédié au budget
primitif de 2016 quelles sont les
premières décisions et comment se
positionnent les élus minoritaires des
communes de gauche eux qui viennent
d'obtenir du tribunal administratif
l'annulation de l'élection du président
et des vice-présidents une nouvelle
élection devrait donc se tenir dans les
prochains mois le reportage de Floran
parfaet une minute de silence pour
commencer cette réunion un hommage aux
attentats survenus à Bruxelles mardi 22
mars avant de laisser place aux échang
concernant le budget 2016 de
l'agglomération de Saint-Quentin en
Yveline premier vote avec les 12
communes dans un contexte compliqué de
baisse des dotation de l'État nous avons
encore dû trouver près de 6 millions
d'économie alors nous l'avons fait sans
aucun problème avec enthousiasme aussi
parce que nous ce qui nous tient à cœur
c'est de les habitants de c50in et les
entreprises donc première chose nous
l'avons fait sans augmenter les impôts
donc aujourd'hui pas d'impôt sur les
ménages pas d'impôts sur les entreprises
adopté à 47 voix contre 24 le budget
principal donne la priorité au
développement économique la politique de
désendettement se poursuit et plus de 72
millions d'euros seront alloués à
l'investissement il y a pas de
d'orientation de de définir il y a des
baisses dans des domaines qui peuvent
toucher très directement les habitants
de 50 ans nieline je pense aux
associations je pense au social je pense
également à la culture comme d'ailleurs
l'année dernière et et donc moi ce que
je dirais c'est que ce budget qui aurait
dû être un budget collectif un budget
pour préparer l'avenir est devenu
finalement un budget au lieu d'être 12
on était 12 moins 4 communes totalement
mis de côté un budget de transition car
les C nouvelles communes de
l'agglomération sont intégrées dans ce
budget à titre Pr isionnel jusqu'à
présent les communes gardent entièrement
leurs recettes donc c'est tout le
travail qui sera fait au cours de cette
année 2016
définir les compétences et surtout le
périmètre des différentes compétences et
c'est là qu'on va savoir ce que nous
allons garder ce que nous allons
diminuer qui va nous permettre ensuite à
travers des transferts financiers des
communes vers l'agglomération ou de
l'agglomération vers les communes de
pouvoir enfin pour la 2017 avoir un vrai
budget à 12 pour un budget à 12 il
faudra donc attendre 2017 à 5 an en
Yveline la JDC la journée défense et
citoyenneté concerne chaque année 800000
jeunes régulièrement contesté elle fait
l'objet d'une attention particulière
depuis les attentats quelques jours
après le nouveau drame qui a endeuillé
la Belgique cette fois-ci nous avons
voulu savoir comment elle se déroulaiit
ces différentes journées et le message
qui était véhiculé diffusé le reportage
de Sephora Anani Aurélie s'initié
conduite deux roues sur simulateur elle
fait partie des 50 appelés à participer
aux ateliers de sécurité routière mis en
place depuis le début de l'année 2016
dans le cadre de la Journée de défense
et citoyenneté cette journée constitue
la 3è étape du parcours de citoyenneté
après une sensibilisation en classe à la
défense et un recensement en mairie dès
l'âge de 16 ans ça nous a permis aussi
de de comprendre le fonctionnement du
code de la route et puis de voir que
derrière derrière nos petit enfin nos
vies il y avait quand même beaucoup de
choses face à la défense du pays ce
dispositif de journée défense
citoyenneté permet aux jeunes
aujourd'hui de bénéficier d'une
explication des enjeux de défense et de
leur rappeler qu'ils ont des droits et
des devoirs en qualité de citoyens la
journée de défense et de citoyenneté
remplace depuis 2011 la journée d'appel
de préparation à la défense elle-même
instituée pour se substituer au service
militaire supprimé en 1997 par Jacques
Chirac les deux grands objectifs de
cette journée n'ont quant à eux pas
changé le
premier consiste en une explication des
enjeux de défense et puis cette JDC
répond à un deuxième objectif le
deuxième objectif consiste en un volet
cohésion sociale puisque la JDC permet
de détecter des jeunes qui soitent en
difficulté de lecture ou des jeunes qui
seraient éventuellement en situation de
décrocheur cette journée était associé
pour l'occasion à la Journée nationale
des réservistes une journée pour
renforcer le lien armé nation et
explique l'engagement des réservistes au
quotidien en France chaque année près de
800000 jeunes Français accomplissent
leurs devoirs en participant à la
journée de défense et de citoyenneté une
journée qui pourrait être remagée à
l'avenir au regard des événements de ces
derniers mois nous passons à l'entretien
à présent de cette édition du vendredi
samedi se déroulera la nouvelle édition
de la rencontre régionale des trophées
de robotique ce sera à Montini
lebretonneux à la Ferme du Manet à
partir de 10h30 pour en parler en
plateau Paula Bruson rouget directrice
adjointe de Planète scienceces île-fance
B bonsoir à vous bonjour et bonsoir
également à Véronique rass directrice de
l'Atelier canopé des ivlines bonsoir
bienvenue donc toutes les deux sur le
plateau pour débuter peut-être quelques
mot sur la manifestation elle existe
depuis 17 ans elle s'adresse aux 7 18
ans donc au plus jeunes ça consiste en
quoi alors c'est une valorisation avant
tout c'est la valorisation de travaux
qui ont été réalisés tout au long de
l'année par des jeunes donc
effectivement de 7 à 18 ans qui ont
travaillé soit en classe soit dans un
club soit voilà dans dans des dans des
atelier en équipe tout au long de
l'année sur un cahier des charges qui
est national qui est celui de la Coupe
de France de robotique et qui est aussi
celui TR robot voilà des petits robots
on voit des images des éditions
précédentes voilà tout à fait et du coup
ces robots là sont construits par les
jeunes en entier donc toute la mécanique
toute l'électricité et puis
éventuellement aussi la programmation
euh et du coup ils doivent réaliser un
certain nombre d'actions donc il y a des
actions par thématique cette année c'est
la thématique de la plage donc les
robots ils vont devoir étendre des
serviettes pêcher des poissons voilà
construire des châteaux de sable et
cetera C des charges mais chacun est
libre un petit peu de de d'élaborer son
propre robot ils auront tous des
apparences différentesou tout à fait ils
peuvent faire comme ils veulent du
moment qu'ils réalisent les les actions
parce que ça leur apporte des points ils
peuvent ne pas réaliser l'ensemble des
actions ils choisissent des certaines
actions donc ces jeunes sont encadrés
par des professionnels pendant plusieurs
mois certains oui d'autres non il y a
des équipes qui sont presque autonomes
parce parce que ils sont sinrire toute
seulle au tout à fait parce que ils ont
16 17 ans et ils peuvent le faire de
même et il y en a certains qui sont avec
leurs enseignants ou avec des parents
donc les épreuves vous nous avez dit
cette année étendre des serviettes des
choses comme ça il y a des surprises
quelquefois euh oui il y a une funy
action donc chaque année on essaie de de
de réaliser des des actions qui vont
permettre de défis pour les équipes et
que ce soit que ce soit rigolo donc
c'est rigolo et pour ceux qui
participent et ceux qui VI y assister
puisque c'est ouvert pour le le grand
public c'est à partir de 10h30 he oui
tout à fait et juste en dehors de des
des actions des des équipes il y a aussi
un certain nombre de partenaires qui
seront là et du coup qui qui feront des
animations supplémentaires toute
transition qui est tout trouvée avec
l'atelier canopé des ivlines puisque
vous êtes venus justement avec les les
quelques robots qui vont être qui vont
être présentés déjà canopé 78 une petite
présentation alors l'atelier canopé des
Yvelines situé à marli Leroi c'est la
structure départementale qui dépend du
réseau canopé opérateur euh opérateur du
ministère de l'éducation nationale ex
Centre national de documentation
pédagogique donc vous serez présent sur
sur cette compétition parce que c'est
une compétition on va revenir tout à
l'heure mais il a un vrai concours entre
entre équipes et vous allez présenter
des plusieurs robots voilà donc nous
sommes nous sommes présents en tant que
partenaire sur sur la partie atelier et
nous allons proposer au aux familles aux
jeunes aux plus jeunes là vous voyez les
les robots sont des robots qui en
particulier la petite Abe qui s'adresse
à à des enfants des la maternelle il y a
le Bibot c'est ça la Biotte la Biot
c'est la AB alors c'est c'est pas un
robot c'est un automate euh qui voilà il
faut ou oui pour pour les enfants c'est
important donc ça s'adresse à des
enfants à partir de à partir de de 4 5
ans mais jusque jusqu'à la fin de
l'école élémentaire on peut tout à fait
on peut tout à fait l'utiliser et et
donc sinon on présentera timio alors io
qui lui est un V présenter à la caméra
non non il suffit de regarder en face de
vous juste en face de vous ou je vous le
prendre voilà je vous l'ER merci
et donc ce modèle alors ce modèle ça
c'est timio c'est un un véritable robot
qui a été développé par le PFL l'École
polytechnique fédérale de Lausanne c'est
un robot pour l'éducation et pourquoi
est-ce que c'est un robot parce qu'il a
de véritables capteurs donc vous avez
les capteurs sur le dessus les capteurs
deent des capteurs qui permettent de
détecter des obstacles et qui permettent
de de tourner lorsqu'ils voit un
obstacle ou de s'arrêter et ce sont
surtout des robots qui existent en mode
préprogrammé par exle exemp là voilà
quand il est en vert si vous appuyez sur
le bouton rond par que je vais réussir à
si les enfants de 6 ans y arrivent
j'raisir stir alors l'intérêt de ce
robot c'est que justement on va mettre
les enfants en démarche d'investigation
c'est eux qui vont découvrir comment
fonctionne ils vont découvrir les
capteurs et donc là ben je vous laisse
essayer de découvrir comment faire
avancer le robot c'était pas prévu je
pense que une petite séquence
sympathique non plus non plus non plus
tant que c'est rouge j'imagine qu'on
peut pas c'est très compliqué hein alors
je je vous rappelle il y a des capteurs
vous avez des capteurs un petit peu
partout cache pas qu'on est en train de
se moquer de moi dans l'oreille avec les
capteurs avec les capteurs en donc les
enfants l'appellent l'appelleent le
petit chien parce qu'évidemment là vous
voyez il va il va nous suivre et on a
plusieurs modes donc je c'est pour
changer de mode voilà pour changer de
mode si maintenant je le mode je le mets
pardon en mode jaune là il est autonome
aussi voilà il va être
autonome voilà alors derrière tout ça
l'apport pédagogique parce que forcément
les enfants doivent tout de suite s'y
intéresser mais mais derrière quoi déjà
la découverte des sciences puisqu'on est
en démarche d'investigation on essaie de
de comprendre comment fonctionne cet
objet technologique et ensuite la
deuxième la deuxième partie ça va être
la programmation parce qu'ensuite on va
le brancher sur l'ordinateur et il y a
un environnement complet un
environnement qui est qui est libre
c'est un logiciel libre qui va permettre
qui va permettre aux enfants de
programmer chacun des capteurs et donc
d'en faire un véritable un véritable
robot qui va pouvoir qui va pouvoir être
utilisé soit soit dans des challenges
soit on peut les faire se suivre aussi
si on si on le souhaite et ce qui est
sympa aussi c'est qu'on a des empreintes
de Lego donc on va pouvoir utiliser des
engrenages on va pouvoir le faire
marcher et pour pour les élèves c'est
aussi je parle d'élèves parce que on les
utilise on les utiliser à l'école
puisqueà la rentrée 2016 la
programmation le codage l'algorithmique
et la programmation rentre
officiellement dans les programmes dès
l'école maternelle et ce sera donc dès
le début de la maternelle les enfants
vont pouvoir utiliser tout ça au début
de la maternelle on va en maternel on va
utiliser les petites abeilles
justementche la petite abeille parce que
là vous voilà vous avez ramené aussi un
petit un petit tapis qui va qui va avec
voilà donc un petit tapis alors le quand
on est à l'école souvent ce sont les
enseignants qui créent leur propre tapis
avec avec les enfants donc et bien là il
va falloir il va falloir faire se
déplacer se déplacer la bille par
exemple si je veux qu'elle aille voir le
le petit moineau et bien je vais avancer
d'une de tris cases je vais tourner à
gauche et ravancer d'une case donc je
vais programmer d'accord on le programme
se déplacer tout seul et j'appuie sur Go
et normalement si je ne suis pas
trompé voilà et comme ça vous voyez
c'est magique tout ça forcément les
enfants doivent tout de suite y trouver
un intérêt en tout cas ça focalise
focalise l'attention bravo vous avez
réussi l'exercice c'est c'est niveau 5
ans c'est ça là 4 5 ans en même temps
j'ai pas réussi tout à l'heure à faire
marcher l'autre donc c'est pas mieux
pour le concours c'est c'est la même
chose le but c'est de d'apprendre des
techniques mais aussi de montrer aux
enfants qu'on peut travailler ensemble
en équipe autour de tout ça pourquoi pas
plus tard susciter des vocation tout à
fait c'est tout à fait l'idée et donc du
coup on travaille souvent c'est la
démarche en fait qu'on applique au
réseau planète science donc on a un
réseau national et l'idée c'est c'est
vraiment de de développer des projets
en équipe dans une démarche
expérimentale qu'évoqué Véronique à
l'instant donc là il y a la partie pour
les démonstrations les les différents
ateliers qui on on lieu en marche du
concours si on revient sur le concours
comment ça va se passer il y a des
manches il y a des finales qu'est-ce qui
é éliminatoire queles sont alors ça
commence à 10h30 donc avant 10h30 les
équipes vont arriver mais elles auront
du temps pour homologuer leur robot donc
ils arrivent il va falloir que les
arbitres vérifient que ça correspond
bien au cahier des charges et on va les
aider pour pouvoir sintion plus de
travail pour on a un atelier pour le
donner un coup de main pour pour
finaliser le robot si jamais il y a il y
a le robot qui est trop large quelque
chose qui ne va pas qui qui s'est cassé
pendant le voyage du coup ils vont
travailler ils vont travailler dessus et
par la suite à 10h30 il va y avoir les
première manch donc il y a trois manches
et ensuite il y a les 8è les quarts les
demi-finales et les finales et il y aura
une remise de prix à 18h est sur
lesépreuves régionales il y a encore une
finale après qui est nationale tout fait
donc il y aura des équipes qui seront
qualifiées à la finale nationale qui
aura lieu à saint-centin mais dans
l'aine et et eux ils vont partir donc
pour une une finale qui va durer 2 jours
le 9 et le 10 avril et par la suite il y
aura aussi une finale internationale
donc je sais pas où est-ce qu'elle va
avoir lieu pour le moment mais en tout
cas il y aura une finale internationale
eurobo et en général l'île-de-fance le
département des ivelines se débrouille
bienette comp alors il y a assez peu
d'équipe yvelinoise on a envie de
développer ces choseslà surtout sur le
territoire de SaintQuentin on aimerait
bien on aimait bien développer des plus
d'équipes euh parce que les équipes
elles viennent de partout dans l'île-
de- France donc voilà mais c'est ça
change d'une année sur l'autre voilà et
ça marque la fin de l'entretien voilà
très bien merci beaucoup à toutes les
deux d'être venu donc en plateau nous
parler tout ça vous vouliez juste
ajouter r Oui juste ajouter que
justement sur les ivelines on a des
challenges qui sont en train de se
mettre en place un challenge bah sur
Saint-Quentin qui s'appelle Sky Rob et
qui touche l'ensemble du bassin
d'éducation de Saint-Quentin et qui se
terminera par une par une rencontre le
26 mai au Palais des Sports des lancours
donc qui touchera 22 classes de de la de
la communauté d'agglomération et le
Conseil départemental qui a lancé un
challenge qui s'appelle robotique et qui
touche trois collèges un d'élancour un
d'orgeerus et un de Ben et dont la
finale aura lieu le 13 juin donc je
pense que l'année prochaine les équipes
evvelinoise feront partie ensite pouront
participer à ce concours à ce trophée de
robotique les finales régionales qui
pour l'île-de-fance qui se déroule à
Montini le Bretonneux à partir de samedi
10h30 nous y reviendrons bien sûr dans
nos prochaines éditions en début de
semaine prochaine merci à toutes les
deux nous poursuivons ce journal avec la
reprise des grandes zoau musicales à
Versailles un spectacle qui perdure
depuis maintenant 350 ans on est loin
des différents robots qu'on a vu tout à
l'heure depuis Louis XIV le reportage
sur les dernières répétitions avant
l'arrivée des visiteurs c'est avec
Michel
[Musique]
elmid
1666 Louis X inaugure les premières
ronzo de versaill sous le regard de son
jardinier André leenautre et de sa cour
350 ans plus tard les 55 bassins et
fontaines et 600 jeux d'eau font
toujours la fierté de la cité royale
chaque printemps les 15 bosquets
s'ouvrent au public 72 représentations
musicales seront programmées dans les
jardins de ce vendredi 25 mars jusqu'à
la fin octobre pour moi c'est un
spectacle à partentière qui en plus nous
permet de découvrir les bosquet comme
vous le savez les bosquets sont autant
de petites pièces dans les jardins de
Versailles
comme des salons de verdures que l'on
peut découvrir grâce à ces grandes eaux
et on peut aussi admirer ces fontaines
qui sont toutes différentes donc on a le
mélange des arts très chers à Versailles
les sculptures les eaux le dessin des
jardins le charme des grandes zoau
musical provient également du mécanisme
des fontaines les 35 km de canalisation
hydraulique sont restés inchangés les
méthodes pour les actioné date également
du 17e siècle la préoccupation
principale des gens c'est de savoir
comment ça fonctionne parce que les gens
pensent que tout fonctionne avec des
pompes donc à ça on dément complètement
c'est encore le système comme sous
l'époque du roi c'est un système
gravitaire il y a pas du tout de pompe
qui font fonctionner les fontaines les
grandes eau musical de versill attire
entre 10000 et 12000 visiteurs par
jour comme chaque vendredi nous passons
à présent à l'essentiel de l'actualité
le zapping des sujets développé dans ce
journal depuis
lundi c'est une élection sans surprise
ce matin Patrick deidjan a été élu
président du conseil d'administration de
l'établissement public
interdépartemental des Yvelines et des
hautes scèes Pierre Bédier a pris ses
fonctions de vice-président de cette
pays qui aura son siège dans la commune
de véisi symbole de la jonction entre
les deux départements vous avez obtenu
72,25 % des suffrages contre 27,75 %
pour votre adversaire vous vous
attendiez à cette issue
non je m'attendais à une is favorable vu
les éléments du premier tour mais pas à
autant d'électeurs qui nous a fait
confiance on nimaginait pas dépasser 70
% c'est une déception une déception pour
deux points le premier c'est c'est la la
non mobilisation de l'électorat puisque
puisque uniquement 26 % des électeurs
sont rendus aux jurnnes comme je disais
déjà la semaine dernière c'est vraiment
l'échec de notre système démocratique
qu'il faut vraiment commencer à à le
repenser en en profond
c'est un signe pour une espérance en
fait pour 2017 mais je pense que c'est
le constat en fait est à l'opposé de ce
que ditjac je pense que si le
gouvernement est est sanctionné c'est
pas parce qu'il a porté la lo comer
c'est simplement parce qu'il a pas de
vision et parce que la vérité
d'aujourd'hui n'est pas la vérité de
demain aujourd'hui lundi 21 mars c'est
la journée mondiale de la trisomie 21
une journée pour sensibiliser le public
à cette maladie pour nous en parler
Christian leco président de l'antenne
départementale des ivelines de
l'association ition française pour la
recherche sur la trisomie 21 ouverte à
Montini le Bretonneux il y a un an
mercredi 23 mars Journée célébration à
l'panema du plateau de sacley depuis le
1er mars cette plateforme de recherche
européenne dédiée à l'étude des
matériaux anciens est devenue partenaire
de l'Université de Versailles
Saint-Quentin pour l'occasion le
secrétaire d'État chargé de
l'enseignement supérieur a fait la
visite du laboratoire le département
doit obligatoirement réaliser 224 places
supplémentaires ainsi qu'au moins de
aires de grand passage d'ici 2019 sur la
route nationale 10 dans la commune des
essardlererois un terrain proche de
l'actuelle air d'accueil est envisagé ce
projet est loin de faire l'unanimité en
décembre une pétition contre cette
implantation a été mise en place la
police municipale de voisin lebretonux
sera-t-elle bientôt armée le débat a été
lancé par Olivier Fonzo conseiller
municipal d'opposition lors du conseil
municipal du 16 février je pense d'abord
à nos policiers municipaux parce que
c'est d'abord eux qui se retrouvent face
au danger c'est pas nous les élus c'est
la police municipale qui se retrouve
face au terroristes le terroriste ne
choisit pas il ne réfléchit pas 2
secondes si c'est un policier municipal
ou si la police nationale c'est un sujet
qui a déjà été soulevé à voisin il y a
quelques années et le maire à l'époque
avait fait une demande à la préfecture
qui a été
refusée aujourd'hui je pense que la
question mérite d'être
reposée voilà ceci dit moi je suis assez
mesuré quand même sur le sujet il y a eu
quelques modifications qui ont été
faites néanmoins l'essentiel des des
réformes rétrogrades qu'elle comprend à
savoir la possibilité pour un patron de
diminuer arbitrairement le salaire la
possibilité d'augmenter le temps de
travail sans augmentation de salaire la
possibilité de radier les 11 heur de
pause toutes les 24 heures de travail
tout ce qui fait enfin la qualité
rétrograde de cette de cette loi est
toujours présente l'équipe de France des
moins de 20 ans était à plaisir pour
participer au tournoi international
junior une compétition qualificativ pour
les championnats du monde 2016 qui
réunissaient la Slovénie la Macédoine et
l'Israël après deux victoires contre les
Slovènes 30 à29 et contre les Israéliens
44 à 16 la France jouit sa qualification
contre la Macédoine ce dimanche un match
qu'elles ont dominé de bout en bout
score final 33 à 21 voilà pour le résumé
de la semaine un mot à présent des
sujets que nous développerons à partir
de mardi lundi est en Ferrier le
prochain journal ce sera mardi à 18h il
sera question notamment de la nouvelle
mobilisation contre la loi travail le 31
mars le mot d'ordre ce sera tous dans la
rue pour un retrait dénonçant je cite
une régression sociale la Cgt Force
Ouvrière la FSU l'Union Syndicale
solidaire l'UNEF l'UNL l'Union des
lycéens la fidèle également syndicat de
lycéens ont appelé à des grèves et à des
manifestations ce sera donc le 31 mars
et puis sur un plan plus local nous
parlerons également de la réouverture de
la Cité des Métiers le 1er avril la Cité
des Métiers de 50 ans en Yveline ce
centre d'information et d'orientation
situé à trappe fpau neuve nouveau projet
nouvelle direction les détails à suivre
dans notre prochaine édition à noter
également à partir de ce weekend sur
notre antenne un nouveau numéro du café
politique je reçois au bistr du théâtre
à Montini le Breton Jean-Pierre Sevestre
vice-président de 50 ans en Yveline en
charge du sport maire de coignère maire
sans étiquette il occupe ce poste depuis
maintenant presque un an après la
démission de son prédécesseur Henri
paayux élu depuis 1986 les deux hommes
ont d'ailleurs aujourd'hui des échanges
plutôt compliqués écoutez cet extrait
dès les premiers les premières semaine
lorsque j'ai pris
la le poste de maire de
coignère Monsieur paayux souhaitait
participer également aux différentes
réunions aux
différentes aux différentes préparations
qu'il pouvait y avoir pour notre
intégration au sein de ce qui s'appelle
maintenant Saint-Quentin en iveline et
donc ce que je ne souhaitais pas Henri
paayux pendant 29 ans a servi la commune
d'une façon extraordinaire et
donc N relation
tendue me me contrarie me contrarie
actuellement bien sûr mais je pense que
lorsque nous une personne est restée
aussi longtemps à la tête d'une commune
rester pour la suite c'est très
difficile c'est très difficile je pense
pour la personne qui souhaite rester
mais pour la personne qui le remplace
successeur c'est trèsile voilà pour moi
c'est très difficile je ne P je pense
que je dois assurer je dois assurer mon
poste et donc mon prédécesseur aurait pu
effectivement me donner des conseils h h
hein mais euh ça n'a pas été le cas ça a
été plutôt
euh des relations qui sont qui sont
devenues tendu Jean-Pierre svestre qui
sera aussi l'invité de Nicolas kirilovit
sur Radio sensation dimanche à 18h pour
l'ebdo politique cette fois-ci je vous
souhaite un très bon weekend pour vos
sorties vos loisirs dans un instant le
7-8 weekend avec Sephora Namani à mardi
donc pour le retour de l'actualité
locale et n'oubliez pas de changer
d'heure ce weekend à 2h il sera 3h dans
la nuit de samedi à dimanche nous
perdrons donc 1h à
mardi